the show is so fascinating but obviously
any show that has religion politics
faith you know there's gonna be a lot of
people with a lot of opinions is that
something that you're prepared for I
think this show was designed to create
that in a way it's the show in itself is
really an invitation to the viewers to
discuss make their own mind up to argue
about it too so I think it's a show that
you it's it's not a singular experience
I think is to show that you invite
people to watch it with other people
I think after every episode you'll want
to discuss what you think what do you
think is a misconception that people
might have about the show misconception
like something that you feel like people
might think right off the bat or
something that you want people to know
about this here's what his here's the
misconception that might happen that the
show is trying to tell people what to
think and that the show is going to give
people answers and the show doesn't tell
people what to think and it doesn't give
people answers the show is told in like
a Russian kind of style where the
character the central character that
many plays is a mystery and you only
ever get to understand that character
through a pastiche of their points of
view so ultimately you never get to see
what he is you have to make your own
mind up maybe what did you want to take
on a role like this said again oh why
did you want to take a role like this oh
it's not really about what I want or
what I don't want it felt like it was
part of my journey really really felt
like everything in my life was going to
prepare me for that role and it happened
like that really was really like a
flowing thing was there a lot of
collaboration between the two of you to
develop this role I think in terms of
the portrayal of the role there was lots
of collaboration the role was written
but and Mehdi was incredibly respectful
of what was written but what's on page
is not necessarily always what you get
when you go to film it but I think this
was one of those very serendipitous
circumstances where the script really
met the perfect casting and so it kind
of came together very easily that being
said it wasn't an easy role for Mehdi to
play and I think one of the biggest
issues in the in the portrayal of the
role is his a question mark is an enigma
he's a secret and so many had to kind of
keep the secret of who he was to himself
until now anybody why do you think now
is the right time for a show like this I
think it's a show like this I I think
it's the show is very zeitgeist II but I
think if the show was written 10 years
ago it would feel as zeitgeist II to be
honest because I think the show concerns
itself with what's going on here and now
and I think as soon as you commit to a
show doing that then the show will tap
into the zeitgeist which I think the
show does so it feels relevant because
it concerned itself with what's going on
the same I mean really it feels like you
know people are really in the search
like in the world what's going on people
are really in search for meaning and and
and yeah